hello fellow tarnish my name is jake and
welcome back to another elden ring video
today i'm going to explain how to finish
fia deathbed companion's full quest line
this will also unlock a secret hidden
boss i don't know why you click on this
video if you were concerned about
spoilers but here's your only warning to
start fia's quest line you'll need to
complete randy's quest line until you
get the finger slayer blade this has you
enter nocron the eternal city after
defeating star scourge radon and you'll
find a room underneath a giant statue of
a giant finger reader to get here right
across this giant bridge and take a left
at the singing lady to rest at the site
of grace you'll make your way through
the under part of the city until you
come across a long walkway with a giant
statue toward the end fight your way
through until you reach a chest
underneath the statue this is where
you'll receive the finger slayer blade
once you have this blade it's time to
find the curse mark of death head back
to rani's rise and talk to her until she
gives you an inverted statue go into the
carrion study hall located here on your
map and place the carrion inverted
statue on the pedestal in the first room
you'll now need to work your way through
the tower until you reach the divine
tower here you can find the curse mark
of death from the top of this tower with
this in hand it's time to go back to fia
and keep the questline going head on
over to fia in the round table hold and
let her hold you one more time because
you've probably already gotten a lot of
hugs from her at this point you should
be able to have a conversation option
regarding a dagger if it's not there try
talking to her about everything else
first and it should appear you'll now
need to find the weathered daggers owner
the good news is that they aren't very
far away as the owner d is just sitting
in the other room now this quest line
will spell the end of mr d so make sure
you've talked to him as much as you want
before going over and handing him the
dagger rest at the round hole side of
grace and you should see that diaz
disappeared now if you go past the
blacksmith huge you'll see that the door
on the top floor at the back behind him
is now open go into this room and you
will find fia there and you can talk to
her exhausting her dialogue will have
fia go off on her own journey and it
means it's time for you to continue
yours thea will now move to the deep
root depths this is an area you can get
via the aqueduct in nocron to get here
head over to the ancestral woods side of
grace from here head northeast and up
until you spot some jellyfish need to
follow this path and drop down and
you'll find the aqueduct facing cliffs
site of grace this entire area is sort
of a mini dungeon that ends with a fight
against two massive gargoyles definitely
not an easy fight
beat them and you'll notice a small
coffin at the back of the boss arena you
need to climb into this coffin and
you'll find yourself in the deep group
deaths near the great waterfall crest
site of grace you'll need to take a
right and across the chasm using the
roots once past the roots you'll need to
keep going towards the cliff edge and
should spot the nameless eternal city
site of grace rest at this and then
continue into the city when you're in
the ruins traverse up the rooftops and
the roots to make your way to the across
the roots site of grace from here simply
go inside the large area and you'll
fight fia's champions again not an easy
fight toward the end once you've beaten
this boss you'll get a new side of grace
and fia should be near the back of the
area near the teleport gate if she isn't
rest at the side of grace or travel
elsewhere and then come back go over to
fia and then given the choice say you
want to be held
from here keep talking to fia until you
give her the curse mark of death which
you already got in your inventory
because i told you to get that earlier
and you can thank me now you will now
need to go back to the side of grace and
rest then talk to fia again repeat this
until you're unable to talk to her
because she's decided to take a nap from
giving out so many hugs to dead people
you'll be able to interact with fia and
you can then enter the death bed's dream
doing so will lead you into a boss fight
with the lich dragon forta sax a secret
optional dragon boss once you've
defeated this boss you'll be taken out
of the dream where you will find d has
killed fia in her sleep he gloats over
her body seemingly losing his mind and
you can do with him as you wish this is
just a side note if you do choose to
kill him you'll receive his armor and
his weapon you can also grab fia's armor
set on her body this will then complete
fia's questline thank you guys for
watching if you enjoyed the video and
want to see more leave a like and
comment what you would want to see next
and also don't forget to subscribe to
the channel thank you guys and i'll see
you in the next one peace and love
[Music]
you